[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى
360 نبدا كالعاده للعناوين
الشرق الروسيه
نحن من قتلنا في بخموت وليس جيشك
والاوكرانيون لا يهربون
غو
تحذر واشنطن من خطها الاحمر في تايوان
وتقارير ترصد عجزا امريكيا خطيرا عن خوض
حرب كبرى
البيت الابيض يرحب بدعوه اللجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ لتحقيق اممي حول
مواقع التعذيب السريه في ايران
لدينا ايضا في العربيه 360
[تصفيق]
رام الله تتهم اسرائيل بشان حرب المفتوحه
على الفلسطينيين بعد اقتحام لجنين اسفر عن
مقتل سته اشخاص
اهلا بكم في ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا عادت
شكاوى مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه من تضييق
الجيش عليه يافيجيني بريجوتين رد على وزير
الدفاع قائلا ان قوات فاجنر هي التي تقاتل
في بخموت وليست قوات الجيش الروسي كما
اوضح ان عناصر القوات الاوكرانيه لا
يهربون وانما يقاتلون بشكل جماعي
ويستسلمون كخيار اخير
معركه باخوت التي اشعلت الشتاء الاوكراني
باتت تحمل الرمزيه الاكبر في الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني
المدينه التي تسمى ايضا
تقع شرقيه اوكرانيا شماليه اقليم دونيتس
تحديدا والذي تتقاسم القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه السيطره عليه القتال الدموي
المستمر منذ اشهر في المدينه والذي حمل
تقدما روسيا في الايام الاخيره ادى الى
قطع الطرق المؤديه اليها باستثناء طريق
وحيده تصل الى الغرب سلطات دنيا المواليه
لروسيا تزعم ان القوات الروسيه استطاعت
السيطره على نصف المدينه محققه تقدما من
الجهتين الشماليه والجنوبيه
قتال مستميد تراه موسكو ذا اهميه
استراتيجيه كبيره للتوغل باتجاه الغرب
الذي تسيطر عليه كييف خاصه وان الهدف
التالي سيكون المدينتين المفتاحتين
كراماتورسك وسلفيانك
تشكل المدينه مركزا دفاعيا مهما للقوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه دومباس والسيطره
عليها ستسمح بهجمات اضافيه في عمق خطوط
الدفاع القوه المسلحه الاوكرانيه لكن رغم
كل هذه الاهميه من وجهه النظر الروسيه فان
واشنطن تقصر اهميه المدينه على الناحيه
الرمزيه وليس الاستراتيجيه وتؤكد ان
التقدم الروسي فيها لن يعني تغيير مسار
المعركه الى عمر العربيه
هذا وقال الرئيس الاوكراني في تصريحات
لشبكه سي ان انسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه من
ضخمه سيفتح الطريقه امام القوات الروسيه
لاحتلال المدن الاخرى واضاف الرئيس
الاوكراني ان روسيا تريد السيطره على
سلوفيا
الى ان روسيا تحتاج لانتصار في بخموت
لتعيد تعبئه المشاعر لدى شعبها على حد
قوله
منكافي ينضم الي مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
حذيفه اهلا بك معنى من خلال تصريحات
زيلينسكي يبدو بانه لا تخلي عن مخموت مهما
كلف الامر هل هناك من مؤشرات على هذا
التمسك بباخ مت على الارض
مساء الخير ميسون يعني على الرغم من اللغط
الذي دار حول مدينه بخموت ان لابد من
الانسحاب منها وان هنالك خلاف بين القياده
السياسيه والعسكريه القرار اتخذ بالجماع
بالاجماع بين الرئيس فلاديميرسكي وفاليزل
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه والقائي
وقائد القوات البريه الكسندر
القرار اتخذ بعد مشاورات واسعه تمت لاكثر
من ساعه ونصف تم الحديث بشكل مفصل ودقيق
حول الوضع في ضخموت زيلينسكي قال كما اشرت
قبل قليل الا انه
الجبهه في باخمه تؤدي الغرض المطلوب منها
بالضبط والان الجبهه يعني السلطات
الاوكرانيه تنظر الى مخمود بشكل مختلف
يعني الهدف الاستراتيجي تغير من قبل عده
اسابيع كان قبل عده اسابيع هو بعد تركيز
القوات الروسيه على هذه الجبهه بشكل كبير
هو ان يتم التمسك بها
لاشغال القوات في تلك المنطقه حتى تاتي
الامدادات العسكريه كما صرحت السلطات
العسكريه حتى والقياده العسكريه الان
الهدف اختلف تماما كما اشار زيلينسكي
وكذلك كما اشار اليوم الشريفاتي وهو
الناطق الرسمي باسم المجموعه الشرقيه قال
ان الهدف الرئيسي الان هو تدمير اكبر عدد
من القوات الروسيه واستنزاف القوات
الروسيه وتدمير القدره القتاليه للقوات
الروسيه بعد ان اصبحت تركز بشكل كبير
وتلقي بعتاه هائل في هذه الجبهه واعداد
كبيره من القوات طبعا ايضا كان هنالك حديث
عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه تفقد واحد الى
سبعه من القوات الروسيه في هذه المعركه في
ضخمه لذلك هنالك تمسك بها تم تعزيز الخطوط
الدفاع خاصه في الشمال بعد ان كانت القوات
الروسيه بشكل كبير بدات في الاقتحام ولكن
الان تم تعزيز هذه الجبهات وما زال
الاوكرانيين المتمسكين ساعود اليك يا
حذيفه ولكن سنتابع ايضا مع هذا الموضوع
ولكن الان من منظار اخر وهذا التصعيد
الحاصل بين مؤسس باغنر ووزاره الدفاع
فهناك فيديوهات يتم تداولها الان عن شكاوى
ايضا لجنود روس من ان عتادهم قديم يعود
الى اربعينات القرن الماضي فضلا عن طبعا
ما يتحدث به دائما مؤسس فاجنر بانه لا
تصله خاصه على جبهات بخموت نتابع
[موسيقى]
نحن نطالب القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
فلاديمير بوتين ونوصل له هذه الرساله لا
يتم تزويدنا باستراتيجيات او تكتيكات ويتم
دفعنا للمعارك ولا يوجد تنسيق مع القيادات
الميدانيه تنقصنا القوه الناريه ولا توجد
لدينا اجهزه للمراقبه في النهار او الليل
كما تنقصنا المركبات المدرعه بعض الاسلحه
التي نستخدمها تعود لاربعينات القرن
الماضي وتحدث هنا عن القذائف والبنادق
ونحن لسنا وحده مخصصه بالهجوم الذي ارسلنا
له نحن مجهزون فقط للدفاع جنودنا يموتون
دون سبب على الجبهات الاماميه نحن لسنا
لحوما ترما في الجبهات نحن مستعدون للقتال
بكرامه لكننا لسنا لحوما
من موسكو ينضم اليه الان مراسله العربيه
عبد الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا
بدايه ما هو ما هي دقه هذا الفيديو وهذا
التذمر من قبل الجنود الروس وخاصه بانه
ايضا هناك تدمر من مؤسس باغينر تجاه موضوع
جبهه بخمت بالذات
مساء الخير ميسون يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لا
يوجد اي تعليق رسمي لا لدى وزاره دفاع
موسكو ولا لدى الكرملين حول موضوع هذا
الفيديو لكن في الحقيقه ميسون ليست هي
المره الاولى التي يتم نشر مثل هذه
المقاطع على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كما
نلاحظ من هذا من هذا الفيديو بان
التعليقات ونشرها جرى من قبل الجانب
الغربي بعض طبعا يعني القراء لما يحدث في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه يتحدثون اليوم عن وجود
مشكله حقيقيه في تزويد طبعا القوات
الروسيه يعني بالعتاد العسكري بالملابس
بالقوه وغير ذلك بينما طبعا وزاره الدفاع
موسكو حتى هذه اللحظه تنفي كافه هذه
الاخبار وتطمن طبعا الوضع الداخلي حول
امكانيتها تامين كل ما يلزم لتلك القوات
خاصه طبعا
300 الف شخص الذين تم تعبئتهم مع نهايه
العامه الماضي ميسون طبعا
وهو مؤسس مجموعه
يعود باطلاق النار من جديد يعني وجهه
وزاره الدفاع موسكو التي التزمت الصمت
اليوم من جديد في الرد على
ما هو موقفه من هذا التصعيد من قبل
ميسون يعني
يلتزم الصمت ويتحدث بما يخص الموضوع
العسكري بانه لدى وزاره الدفاع لذلك طبعا
هذا السؤال طرح مرات عده بما يخص ما
يطالبه ما تطالب به العمليه العسكريه من
قوات فاجنر هناك في الجنوب الاوكراني
اجابها بسكوف وهو المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الكرملين بان الموضوع لدى وزاره الدفاع
وهي المخول الاول والاخير بالاجابه وبالرد
وبتامين المعدات العسكريه
طبعا الشارع الروسي اليوم منقسم بين باحث
بين باحث عن الحقيقه في نقص المعدات ومن
طبعا يتابع بيانات وزاره الدفاع ويؤمن
بوجود هذه المعدات شكرا لك عبد الجواد
دائما على كل التوضيحات وعلى كل التفاصيل
كنت معي من موسكو وراسل العربيه شكرا لك
اعلن وزير الدفاع البولندي ماريوس بلاشاك
تزويده اوكرانيا بعشر دبابات اضافيه من
طراز ليوبارد المانيه صنع هذا الاسبوع من
جهه اخرى قال بلاشك ان قرار امداد
اوكرانيا المحتمل بالمقاتلات الجويه
الغربيه يجب اتخاذه على مستوى الحلفاء في
النيتو
المساعدات الغربيه لا تتوقف لكن حاله
التململ تزداد في بريطانيا مثلا حذر
برلمانيون من خطوره الوضع في المخازن
العسكريه نتابع
حرب اوكرانيا تهدد مخزونات الذخيره
البريطانيه لاول مره منذ سنوات طويله
بريطانيا تسجل نقصا فادحا في الذخيره
والسبب المساعدات المقدمه للجيش الاوكراني
تململ واستياء ومخاوف كبيره في اوساط بعض
البرلمانيين البريطانيين صاحبتها تحذيرات
من ان اعاده بناء مخزون بريطانيا من
الذخائر قد يستغرق عقدا على الاقل
دعوات حكوميه لتقليص الوقت اللازم
لاستعاده مستويات مخزونات بريطانيا من
الذخيره وكاله البريطانيه الامن القومي
البريطاني بات تحت الخطر بسبب انخفاض
احتياطيات الذخيره الى مستويات خطيره في
الوقت الذي تسعى فيه الدول الغربيه الى
ابقاء كياف مزوده بالذخيره الحربيه عدم
قدره المملكه المتحده على استعاده مستويات
مخزوناتها يع رض قدرتها على اعاده تزويد
الجيش الاوكراني للخطر ويعرضها لخطر عدم
القدره على مواجهه التهديدات التي تطال
امنها في المستقبل
اعتقد انه من الضروري ان نقوم بذلك ساشعر
بالقلق ان لم نكن مستعدين لدعم
الاوكرانيين في هذا الوقت بالذات
شرق وغرب اوروبا يتعرض للتهديد لذا يجب
بذل قصار جهدنا لدعم اوكرانيا اذا كان
الامر صحيحا والمخزون منخفضا فهي مشكله
لكن ان وفر المخزون فلا باس
افترض ان على اي دوله للتاكد من ان لديها
ما يكفي من الذخيره نحن نعيش في عالم غير
امن ونحن بحاجه الى ان نكون مستعدين
مره جديده الى زميلنا في كاف مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه مره جديده اليك
هناك حاله من التململ يعني رايناها عند
بعض البرلمانيين البريطانيين ايضا هناك
حاله من تململ في بعض الدول الغربيه ولكن
كيف
تستقبل اروقه الحكم في اوكرانيا هذا
التممل الاوروبي
نعم في الحقيقه ميسون القياده الاوكرانيه
وخاص القياده السياسيه في اوكرانيا
والعسكريه كذلك متمثله في وزير الدفاع
ومطمئنين تماما لاستمرار عمليات الدعم
الغربيه للجيش الاوكراني بالسلاح والذخائر
وهنالك برنامج موضوع بشكل واضح جدا
وبتوقيتات محدده بعد دراسه كبيره الناتو
لديه مستشارين يعملون على الارض سوى كان
في الجبهات او مع القياده العسكريه هنالك
طبعا الاجتماع الشهري والدوري
للمستشارين الامنيين للجيش الاوكراني من
حلف الناتو اسمحي لي هنا ان استخدم يعني
ما قاله
في بدايه هذه الحرب عندما كان هنالك تململ
من الاوساط الاوروبيه حول الدعم العسكري
للجانب الاوكراني عندما قال بشكل واضح ان
اوكرانيا اليوم تدفع يعني ثمنا باهظا هم
يدفعون ارواحهم ونحن ندفع المال ولكن اذا
لم نقم بدعم اوكرانيا ففي المستقبل القريب
سوف مع ذات الثمن وسوف ندفع ارواحنا هنا
الاوروبيين يعتبرون وخاصه القيادات العليا
تعتبر ان هذه الجبهه هي جبهه
لجميع اوروبا لذلك هنالك يعني هدف مشترك
هو حمايه هذه الجمال لذلك هو مستمرين في
الدعم
القياده الاوكرانيه مطمئنه تماما زياره
الاخيره الى اوكرانيا والى كيف كان الهدف
احد الاهداف الاساسيه منها هو تاكيد
استمرار الوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا وهذا
مؤكده وكذلك القاده الاوروبيين بريطانيا
تحديدا على لسان رئيس وزرائها الحالي
والسابق والاسبق اكدوا انهم مستمرين في
الدعم اما بخصوص الانتاج فهنالك عمليه
زياده للانتاج بدات بالفعل سواء كان من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او من حلف
الناتو شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات من
راس العربيه حذيفه عادل كنت معي من كيف
الحرب مشاهدينا في اوكرانيا تتواصل ويزداد
الدعم لها وهو يعني بشكل مباشر امتلاء
جيوب مصنعي الاسلحه وخزائن الدول نقص
الانتاج الذي يواجه الموردين التقليديين
كالولايات المتحده مثلا ادخل دولا اخرى
على الخط وناخذ مثلا كوريا الجنوبيه
تدخلت لسد الفجوه بينما تحاول عدم استفزاز
موسكو تحركت كوريا الجنوبيه بوتيره سريعه
لانتاج المزيد من الصواريخ والدبابات
وقذائف المدفعيه والذخائر في العام الماضي
ارتفعت صادرات كوريا الجنوبيه من الاسلحه
بنسبه 140 في المئه الى مستوى قياسي بلغ
17 مليار و300 مليون دولار الصعود في خط
الانتاج هو عائد لتلبيه الطلب من قواتها
المسلحه وللحمايه طبعا من كوريا الشماليه
في منطقه اخرى كشفت الصناعات الحربيه
التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه ان
العام الجاري سيشهد قفزه في حجم مبيعات
الاسلحه واوضح التقارير الاسرائيليه ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا قلبت المعادلات في
العالم لتصبح الدول الاوروبيه اكثر
استعدادا لشراء الاسلحه والعتاد والذخيره
الاسرائيليه الصنع
ايضا رحب الامين العام لحلف الناتو يانس
تولتنبرغ بخطوات المجره نحو الموافقه على
انضمام السويد الى الحلف
حتى الان صدق ثمانيه وعشرون من الحلفاء
الثلاثين وبعد ذلك بالطبع امل واحث
الحليفين المتبقيين المجر وتركيا على
القيام بذلك في اقرب وقت ممكن اعلن
البرلمان المجري عن خطه للقيام بذلك قرب
نهايه الشهر ثم مع زياره الوفد للسويد
لارسال رساله ايجابيه اعتقد اننا نحرز
تقدما ونقترب من التصديق ايضا في المجر
اتهم الرئيس البيلاروسيه الاكزندور
لوكاتشينكو المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
ومجموعات اوكرانيه بالوقوف وراء ما وصفه
بالهجوم على طائره عسكريه روسيه بالقرب من
العاصمه منسك
[موسيقى]
عمل جهاز الامن الاوكراني وكذلك وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه سرا وبشكل مشترك على
عمليه ضد جمهوريه بيلاروسيا ما رايناه في
تنفيذ العمليه في بيلاروسيا كان حقا شيئا
لا يصدق تم استخدام اكثر التقنيات تقدما
تلقى المهاجم تدريبا كاملا واستعد لاكثر
من شهر بعد التدريب كما تقول المخابرات
السوفياتيه على اراضينا
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 نتابع بعض لحظات خلال
زيارتهما لبغداد
ميليشيات المواليه لايران وبيربوكس تعتبر
سلوك طهران تهديدا للمنطقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الولايات المتحده هي
المتسببه بتدهور العلاقات مع الصين بحسب
وزير الخارجيه
الوزير اعتبر ان السياسه واشنطن انحرفت
تماما عن المسار العقلاني والسليم وانه
اذا وصلت الولايات المتحده الاسراع في
المسار الخطا فستصل الامور الى حاله صراع
واكد وزير الخارجيه الصيني انه لا ينبغي
لاحد ان يقلل من عزم الصين وشعبها على
الدفاع عن سياده ووحده اراضي البلاد
[موسيقى]
ما تطلق عليه الولايات المتحده حواجز
حمايه وعدم السعي للصراع يعني ببساطه ان
الصين لا ينبغي ان ترد بالافعال او
الاقوال عند الافتراء او الهجوم عليها
وهذا مستحيل اذا لم تضغط الولايات المتحده
على المكابح وواصلت الاسراع في المسار
الخاطئ فلن يمنع اي قدر من الحواجز الخروج
عن المسار وسنصل لصراع ومواجهه ومن سيتحمل
العواقب الكارثيه هذه المنافسه هي مقامره
متهوره ورهان على المصالح الاساسيه
للشعبين وحتى مستقبل البشريه
كيف ستبدو هذه الحرب بين الصين والولايات
المتحده حول وقوعها بسبب تايوان
وضعت تصورا لبعض العوائق امام الطرفين ما
هي مركز دراسات امريكيه اجرى مناوره
افتراضيه العمل الماضي تحاكي هجوما
برمائيا صينيا على تايوان وحينها نفذ
مخزون صواريخ كروز بعيده المدى المضاده
للسفن من الجانب الامريكي في غضون اسبوع
على الطرف الصيني تبدو القوه الصاروخيه
الصينيه مجهزه جدا لامطار القواعد
والموانئ التي تعتمد عليها الولايات
المتحده في المنطقه مناوره حربيه اجرتها
هيئه الاركان في البانتاجون اظهرت ان
الولايات المتحده يمكن ان تعرقل غزوه
صينيا لتايوان اذا جرت الحرب في وقت لاحق
من هذا العقد الا انها لن تستطيع ايقافه
ولتحضير للمستقبل
تخلص بل تخلص السلاح مشاه البحريه من
دباباته ويعيد تشكيل نفسه كقوه تهاجم
السفن الصينيه من الجزر الصغيره في غرب
المحيط الهادئ وسيتم تجهيزه بصواريخ مضاده
للسفن في جزيره اوكينا واليابانيه بحلول
عام 20 25 نبقى في البحر وفيه تواجه
البحريه الامريكيه قيودا على قدره بناء
السفن وتخطط حاليا لتوسيع اسطولها الى ما
لا يقل عن 355 سفينه ماهوله لمواكبه
التطور البحري الصيني بكين من جانبها
تواصل تطوير قواتها الجويه التي تعتبر
اصغر من مثيلتها الامريكيه واختبرت اكثر
من مره صواريخ جديده تفوق سرعتها سرعه
الصوت
[موسيقى]
برنامج التحليل السياسي العسكري في معهد
هاتسونس اهلا بكم معنا اذا اردنا ان نركن
على هذه التقارير وما تبعناها منذ قليل
يجعلنا نتساءل لهذه الدرجه اقوى جيوش
العالم
سينفذ بعض من اسلحتها خلال اسبوع واحد هل
هذا يعقل
نا لنا من خلال الحرب التي تدور روحها في
اوكرانيا ان التحديات الرئيسيه
تتمثل من خلال ما ذكره بعض المسؤولين
الامنيين الامريكيين ومنهم سلبا ان الهدف
الرئيسي هو الحصول على الذخيره وتامينها
لاوكرانيا التي
قد اضطررت
لطلبها من دول اخرى في اسيا وغير وغيرها
ان الماده التي طرحتها قد ذكرت بصوره
واضحه ان الولايات المتحده ليست فقط بحاجه
الى تكنولوجيا افضل بل الى مزيد من
الاسلحه للتوازن مع الصين في اي حرب تقع
في اسيا لذا فان الولايات المتحده تقوم
باعداد العده التي قد تستغرق سنوات طويله
وكما تعلمون فان الولايات المتحده خاضت
حربا بارده وبعدها توقفت عن تسريع انتاجها
من الصناعات الدفاعيه
لسنوات طويله لتجهز نفسها ولكن هذه
التقارير الا تعزز التخوفات من ان تقوم
الصين بشن حربها على تايوان قبل ان تصبح
الولايات المتحده جاهزه لمواجهتها
نعم هناك بعض المخاوف لكن الامل يبقى بان
الولايات المتحده سوف
تقوم بالاعتماد بصوره متزايده على الحلفاء
والشركاء ومن وفي اوروبا الاعتماديه يتم
على النيتو ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي لتقديم
المساعده في مواجهه روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
وفي الشرق الاوسط الاعتماد يتم
الاعتماد على دول الخليج لمواجهه ايران
وفي اسيا يتم العمل بصوره متزايده مع
اليابان واستراليا والهند
وكوريه الجنوبيه من اجل مواجهه الصين لذا
فهذا الامر من شانه ان يجعل الولايات
المتحده تسد تلك الفجوه وفي ذات الوقت
الولايات المتحده تفكر بانه اذا الحقت
الهزيمه
بروسيا وتم رفع العقوبات فهذا سوف يساعد
على ردع الصين من الاقدام على اي حرب تتم
من خلالها قدمي تايوان عنوه نظرا لما قد
يحدث مع روسيا في اوكرانيا
اشكرك من واشنطن مدير برنامج التحليل
السياسي العسكري في معهد هاتسون
وبالتزامن مع الحديث عن توتر مع الصين
انتقد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاسبق
بولتينج من اكبر الصحف في البلاد بتقديم
الاخبار الاكثر فظاعه واستفزازا منذ خمسه
عقود تصريح ياتي بعد ان حذرت صحيفه
ضد الصين في غضون ثلاث سنوات على خلفيه
هجوم الصين على تايوان الصحفتان نشرت
تقريرا استند الى تقييمات لخمسه خبراء في
الامن القومي قالوا في بيان مشترك بعنوان
الانذار الاحمر انهم يعتقدون ان استراليا
تواجه احتمال نشوب نزاع مسلح في وقت لم
يتم فيه اعدادها لمثل هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
اكد دبلوماسيون في مجلس محافظي وكاله
الطاقه الدوليه ان تمهل الغربي في ادانه
ايران بخصوص انشطتها النوويه جاء لمنحها
فرصه للتعاون بعد تصريحات الايجابيه لكن
الدبلوماسيا وصف الامر بانها هدوء ما قبل
العاصفه وعن اجتماعا جديدا في يونيو سيكون
حاسما
وفي لهجه اقرب للمهادنه قال مدير منظمه
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه لاكبر صالحي ان
طهران يجب ان تكون مرنه من اجل الخروج من
المازق السياسي كما لمح الى ان عدم
الاستقرار الاقتصادي هو مؤشر على ان
النظام السياسي في بلد ما قد يواجه طريقا
مسدودا واضاف انه على النظام ان لا يضعف
صورته الدوليه وان يتصرف بطريقه صحيحه كي
لا يزيد عدد المعارضين والاعداء
في الاثناء اعلنت الداخليه الايرانيه
اعتقال اشخاصا على صله بقضيه تسميم الطلاب
في خمس محافظات وكان الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيس اكد ضروره تاهب اجهزه
المخابرات للتعامل مع التهديدات الامنيه
في اي مجال بما في ذلك التهديدات ضد الصحه
العامه
[موسيقى]
خوذه خارجياس
التزامن كشفت معلومات جمعها موقع ايران
انترناشونال تعرضت طالبات في اكثر من 120
مدرسه للتسمم امس واظهرت المعلومات ان هذه
المدارس توزعت في 25 محافظه ايرانيه منها
كردستان وفارس وطهران واصفهان وكرمان
من اصله ينضم الينا دكتور محمود اميري
مقدم رئيس منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
دكتور اهلا بكم معنا يبدو ان الاعتقالات
لمن اذاعوا خبر هذا التسمم اكثر من
الاعتقالات
للمشتبه بهم انتم كمنظمه حقوق انسان هل
لديكم اي احصائيات دقيقه عن عدد الذين تم
توقيفهم وايضا عن عدد الذين تم توقيفهم
لانهم اداعوا الخبر
شكرا جزيلا على استضافته اولا
لابد لنا ان نتذكر
ان هذه الهجمات التي لحقت بفتيات المدارس
لقد مر عليها ثلاثه اشهر
والسلطات الايرانيه لم تفعل ولم تحرك ساكن
البته او بل تجاهلتها
وفي هذا الاسبوع كنا قد سمعنا من المرشد
الاعلى في تصريح له يقول بانهم قاموا
باعتقال بعض الاشخاص هذه المزاعم التي
تقول بانهم اعتقلوا بعض الاشخاص لا
تفتقروا الى الصدقيه فكافه الادله
تشير بالبنان الى حقيقه مفادها ان هذه
الهجمات كانت منظمه ومنسقه بشكل كامل وهي
اما قد تم تنفيذها من قبل السلطات
الايرانيه او
وقعت على يد او بمباركه من السلطات
الايرانيه والسبب ان السلطات الايرانيه
تدعي باعتقالها لمرتكبي عمليات التصميم
هذه بانهم يخشون بان هذا الامر قد يدفع
الى موجه جديده من الاحتجاجات لان هناك
احتجاجات قد طالت مدنا كثيره وتخص
العائلات والطلاب الذين هبوا الذين قد
يهبون الى الشوارع مجددا في بلدات كثيره
من
عمليات الاعتقال قد تكون من قبيلاندا او
الدعايه فقط وهم يرغبون باستخدام الهجمات
تلك من اجل اعتقال بعض الاشخاص
والحكم عليهم بالاعدام ونشري المزيد من
الخوف لا توجد لدينا معلومات دقيقه عن
الاشخاص الذين تم اعتقالهم اما فيما يخص
تلك الهجمات فنحن كنا قد طلبنا
اجراء تحقيق دولي مستقل ونزيه بشان هذه
الهجمات الكيماويه الارهابيه بحقه فتيات
المدارس
اذا ما كانت السلطات الايرانيه تقف خلفها
الدكتور محمود
متى البعض يتحدث بانه توضع مواد كيماويه
في المكيفات البعض يقول بانه يتم رش هذه
المواد الكيماويه داخل الصفوف هل تمكنتم
من معرفه حقيقه ما يجري كيف يتم تصميم
هؤلاء الفتيات وهؤلاء الطالبات
كما تعلمون هناك روايات مختلفه
ففي المره الاولى ومنذ ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا
جاءت سمعنا اخبار عن بعض الفتيات التي
اللواتي تعرضنا
هذه العمليات الهجوميه اذ بداوا يشعرون
بالغثيان وكان من الصعب عليهن التنفس
ومن ثم بدانا بالتقيؤ
وبدت
وعدد كبير من شهود العيان قالوا بان تمت
رائحه غريبه كانت تخرج
عن عند حدوث تلك الحوادث فضلا عن صعوبه في
التنفس لا نعلم قد تحدثنا الى بعض الاطباء
وقالوا انه من الصعب ان يتم تحديد نوع
المواد الكيماويه التي تمت تم استخدامها
لكن الامر المشترك ان هذه المواد
الكيماويه تؤدي الى الى حاله من الاضطراب
في الجهاز التنفسي بالاضافه الى نوع من
الغثيان والتقيؤ بعض الاشخاص قد تم نقلهم
للعلاج في المستشفياته وهناك بعض التقارير
غير المؤكده التي تقول بانه شخص واحد على
الاقل قد تم قتله لكن الامر المؤكد ان
انها مواد كيماويه وهجمات كيماويه وسلطات
الايرانيه
وكما اسلفت القول
كانت تنكر هذه الاحداث قبل ثلاثه اشهر وفي
الفتره الحاليه
حري بنا ان نجري تحقيقا حول طبيعه هذه
المواد المستخدمه ومن يقف خلفها
[موسيقى]
صرح جون كربي منسق مجلس الامن القومي
للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه للعربيه بانه يرحب
بدعوه مجلس الشيوخ لبعثه الامم المتحده
الدوليه لتقص الحقائق بشان ايران
العربيه ان النظام الايراني لديه تاريخ
طويل في خنق المعارضه والعنف ضد الشعب
وانه يجب عدم السماح بانتهاكات حقوق
الانسان بعد ان قتل مئات بل قتل مئات
المتظاهرين على يد السلطه
مباشره من البيت الابيض تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه ناديه بلبيسي ناديه ماذا لدينا من
تفاصيل حول هذا الترحيب وماذا بعد ما هي
الخطوه بعد هذا الترحيب
اهلا بك ميسون بالفعل هذا السؤال واجهته
قبل قبل قليل الى كريم جانبير المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض التي قالت تقريبا نفس
ما قاله جون كربيلي في المكالمه الهاتفيه
طبعا البيت الابيض كما ذكرت يرحب بقرار
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بانه يجب ان يكون
هناك لجنه
لجنه التقصي او او تحقيق امميه ويجب ان
تكون هذه اللجنه شفافه لكن البيت الابيض
يدرك تماما بان ايران لن تسمح بذلك
وبالتالي حاولت ان اسالها ما هي المحاسبه
التي سيقوم بها البيت الابيض ما هي
العقوبات التي ستفرضها الولايات المتحده
لم تجيب بشكل واضح لكن اعتقد بانه الاداره
ليس بيدها الكثير من الادوات غير انها
تعرب عن قلقها اولا اولا بالنسبه لتسميم
الفتيات في المدارس وثانيا بالنسبه لهذه
الاماكن السريه او المعتلقه المعتقلات
السريه التي تقوم بتعذيب طبعا المواطنين
سواء كانوا متظاهرين او معارضين للنظام
وبالتالي قد يكون هناك خطوه قادمه من
البيت الابيض بفرض عقوبات على منتهي حقوق
الانسان لكن بشكل عام الاداره تقول بانه
لا ايران والنظام الايراني تاريخ معروف
بانتهاك حقوق الانسان بقتل طبعا
المتظاهرين وهناك مئات منهم الذين قضوا
باعمال عنف من قبل النظام سواء كان تعذيب
او قتل في الشوارع وبالتالي تدعو المجتمع
الدولي الى وقفه وربما هنا هناك دعوه الى
اوروبا بالتحديد يعني البعض يرى بان
اوروبا احيانا تتساهل بالنسبه للموضوع
الايراني لكن اعتقد الاداره الان وخصوصا
ان هذا كل يوم تقريبا ميسون تسال يعني
المتحدثه باسم الابيض بالنسبه للبيت
الابيض بالنسبه
لتسميم الفتيات وتقول بانها قلقه جدا من
البيت الابيض قلق جدا لكن هناك تصريحات
وهناك افعال ماذا يمكن للبيت الابيض ان
يفعل ادا ره الرئيس بايدن اعتقد بان
العقوبات هي الاداه الوحيده التي يمكن ان
تفرضها على النظام الايراني اشكرك ناديه
على كل هذه التفاصيل كانت معنا من البيت
الابيض مراسله العربيه ناديه بلبيسي شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]
وصفت وزيره خارجيه المانيا عنا لينا بيربو
هجمات ايران عبر حدود العراق بالخطيره على
ان المنطقه واثناء لقائها نظيرها العراقي
في بغداد شددت على ضروره تجنب العنف
الناتج عن الارهاب او عن نفوذ ايران
للحفاظ على استقرار العراق والمنطقه
[موسيقى]
على الدول ان تحترم سياده العراق كما
نتوقع منها ان تحترم سياده كل الدول
الاوروبيه ويظهر النظام الايراني بهجماته
الصاروخيه انه لا يضطهد شعبه بقسوه ووحشيه
فحسب بل يضع حياه الناس والاستقرار في
المنطقه كلها تحت الخطر في سبيل الحفاظ
على قوته وهذا امر غير مقبول وخطير على
المنطقه كامله
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان الرئيس الوزراء
العراقي تعهد بضمان امن القوات الامريكيه
في العراق من جهات غير تابعه للدوله في
اشاره الى الميليشيات المواليه لايران
يجب ان نكون قادرين على العمل بسلامه
وامان لتنفيذ دورنا الحيوي لتقديم المشوره
للقوات العراقيه لذا اود ان اشكر رئيس
الوزراء السوداني ووزير الدفاع العباسي
على التزامهما اليوم بضمان ان قوات
التحالف الموجوده في العراق بطلب عراقي
ستتم حمايتها من العناصر التابعه وغير
التابعه للدوله نركز على مهمه هزيمه داعش
هذا هو هدفنا الوحيد هنا والتهديدات
والهجمات على قواتنا تقوض مهمتنا
عربيه منتظر رشيد
منتظر زياره الى العراق وتصريحات من بغداد
وتحذيراته ايضا من هناك كيف
تلقفتها الجهات المختلفه في العراق
يعني وزير الدفاع الامريكي تحدث صراحه عن
ضروره تضمن الحكومه العراقيه سلامه
المستشارين الامريكي وايضا الجنود
الامريكيين الذي يلقونهم لعملات طبعا
تدريب للقوات العراقيه وما الى ذلك في
اكثر من قاعده عسكريه عين الاسد غرب
الانبار حرير في اربيل في اقصى شمال
العراقي اضافه الى قاعده فيكتوري هنا في
مطار بغداد الدولي اذن وزير الدفاع
الامريكي تحدث عن ضروره حمايه كل هؤلاء
الامريكيين وتحدث عن ذلك بصراحه مع
المسؤولين العراقيين الذين قدموا ضمانات
على عدم تعرض القوات الامريكيه طبعا الى
مثل هذه الهجمات
زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي اثارت ايضا
عاصفه من ردود الفعل من قبل قاده الفصائل
المسلحه في العراق غرد معظمهم رفضا لهذه
الزياره وصفوها بانها زياره غير مرحب بها
ايضا انتقدوا تصريحاته اض انتقادهم حتى
المسؤولين العراقيين الذين استقبلوا اذا
نحن امام عاصفه من الانتقادات التي صدرت
طبعا عن كل هذه الفصائل التي قالت بان
اوستن جاء من الشباك ولم ياتي من الباب في
اشاره طبعا الى ان وزيره دفاع الامريكي لم
يتم الاعلان عن زيارته الى العراق طبعا
لاسباب امنيه لكن هذا كان مثال انتقاد كل
هذه الفصائل التي هل يمكن ارتفاع من
استقبله نعم يعني موجود في العراق ايضا
وزيره الخارجيه الالمنية الالمانيه
قبل ايام هل يمكن اعتبار بان العراق يجني
ثمار التزامه مع ضوابط الولايات المتحده
بما يخص التمويل والبنك المركزي العراقي
بايجاز لو سمحت
يعني العراق على ما يبدو انتهى ومضى بعيدا
طبعا في التفاهم مع الولايات المتحده حول
هذه النقطه تحديدا بزياره وزير الخارجيه
العراق الذي اصطحب معه وفدا اقتصاديا
امنيا الى واشنطن وعدم منها بالتالي تم
وضع الكثير من النقاط على الحروف في هذه
الزياره كما يقولون بالنسبه للزيارات
الاخرى وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ايضا
كانت موجوده ووجهت سيله من الانتقادات
طبعا لايران ربما لانها اقتربت جغرافيا من
ايران وجهت مثل هذه التصريحات والانتقادات
طبعا على كل السياسات الايرانيه بدءا من
قصف القواعد او المناطق في اقليم كردستان
وصولا طبعا الى التدخل الايراني حسب
تعبيرها في الشان العراقي والاضرار
بالمنطقه ككل نتيجه هذه التدخلات التي
تحدثت عنها وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه لكن
الجانب الاقتصادي من هذه الزياره هو الذي
كان الابرز حيث تم توقيع ثلاثه عقود كبيره
جدا
لاقامه محطات
كهربائيه لتوليد الكهرباء بالطاقه او
بالغاز بالتالي شركه كانت لها الحصه
الاكبر وهناك الكثير من العقود التي
على ما يبدو سيتم توقيعها ايضا خلال
الفتره المقبله اذا الجانب الاقتصادي كان
حاضرا بقوه وايضا انتقاد ايران ايضا كان
مشتركا مع وزير الدفاع الامريكيه الذي وان
لم يشير طبعا صراحه الى ايران لكنه تحدث
عن اذرعان في العراق وايضا ضروره يعني عدم
السماح لها باستهداف المصالح الامريكيه
اشكرك دائما على كل هذه المعلومات وتفاصيل
والتوضيحات كنت معي مراسل العربيه منتظر
رشيد من بغداد
[موسيقى]
قلا وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان ان السعوديه منفتحه على الحوار مع
ايران مضيفا ان الاتفاق النووي مع ايران
ليس مثاليا ويجب ان يعالج مخاوف دول
الجوار واكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه انه
يوجد اجماع على ان الوضع في سوريا ليس
مقبولا وانه يوجد حوار لعوده سوريا الى
الحضن العربي لكن من المبكر الحديث عن ذلك
وحول الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه اكد
الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان موقف السعوديه
واضح وهو استقرار وامن الفلسطينيين مشيرا
الى انه توجد احتماليه لمواجهه عنف اكبر
اذا لم يتم حل القضيه الفلسطينيه ايضا
اضاف وزير الخارجيه السعوديه ان العلاقه
مع البيت الابيض جيده جدا كما ان الصين من
اكبر الحلفاء التجاريين الرياض كما هي مع
باقي العالم وحول اسواق الطاقه اكد الوزير
ان وزاره الطاقه لا ترى حاجه لتغيير انتاج
النفط هذا العام وان السعوديه ملزمه
باستقرار اسواق الطاقم كما علق وزير
خارجيه السعوديه عن تقارير حول تباعد في
تباعد في العلاقات مع الامارات واكد ان
مثل هذه التقارير عاده ما تكون مبالغا
فيها
[موسيقى]
اتهمت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه اسرائيل بشن حرب
مفتوحه على الفلسطينيين بعد اقتحام لمخيم
جنين اسفر عن مقتل السته الفلسطينيين
بينما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف
منفذ عمليه حواره
شباب شباب هيا
هيا ايات خاصه هياها هياها يا شباب
كما افادم الرسول العربيه باسقاط طائره
مسيره للقوات الاسرائيليه في مخيم جنين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
360 نتابع بعد قليل حرب اوكرانيا تنعش
سوقا موازيه للاسلحه اسلحه قابله للنفخ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في تركيا حسمت المعارضه
خيارها بترشيح كمان
امام الرئيس اردوغان في انتخابات الرئاسه
ليبدا الحديث عن اهم الوعود التي سيقدمها
لاقناع النخبيين باختياره
مثقلون بخيبات في انتخابات العقدين
الماضيين
ومتوشحا بفوز يتيم في اخر انتخابات محليه
هذا هو حالك مالك الجدار اوغلو الذي غدا
مرشحا مشتركا لتحالف الامه المعارض اكبر
تحالف انتخابي معارض للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان الوصول الى نقطه التفاهم حول
المرشح المشترك تطلب ولاده قيصريه ومعها
يبدو مشهد المعارضه غير منسجم الى حد بعيد
وهذا بحد ذاته قد يمثل عائقا امام وصولك
الجدار اوغلو لقلوب وعقول الناخبين بغيه
اقناعهم لكن انصاره يرون ان صمود تحالف
الامه هو بطاقه عبور مرشحهم المشترك نحو
الظفر بالانتخابات
كمال كلتش هو زعيم لتحالف يضم سته احزاب
مختلفه هو يرتبط بقوه الطاوله السداسيه اي
ان هذه الطاوله صنعت كمال كالجدار اوغلو
لذلك يوجد ايجابيه في هذه النقطه
امام زعيم المعارضه اسابيع قليله فقط
ليثبت انه ند لاردوغان لذا عليه تقديم
اوراق اعتماد قويه للشارع الذي يتطلع لحل
مشاكل استعصت على حكومه الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان وفي مقدمتها الازمه
الاقتصاديه
بالطبع المشاكل التي ستواجهك الجدار اوغلو
عديده منها تجديد نظام الحكم والثانيه هي
مشكله تركيا الكبيره وهي المشكله
الاقتصاديه كما تعلمون تركيا تتاثر منذ
عده سنوات بالمشاكل التي تعصف بالعالم
يمكننا الحديث عن مشكله اقتصاديه كبيره
لاجل ذلك يجب القيام بشيء اتجاهها
ايضا من الملفات التي يتعين على
تقديم حلول لها هي الاثار الكارثيه التي
خلفها الزلزال المدمر في السادس من فبراير
الماضي
يقلل كثيرون من ازمه تحالف الامه المعارض
التي سبقت اختيار المرشح المشترك ويرى
هؤلاء ان معارضي اردوغان سيقبلون باي
شخصيه تنافس الرئيس الحالي لكن في المقابل
هناك وجهه نظر اخرى تعتقد ان كلجدار اوكلو
لن يكون بكفاءه اردوغان فضلا عن كونه لا
يحظى بقبول كبير في الشارع كرسي بلديه
اسطنبول وانقره زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 3
تعاني نقصا يصل الى الربع في عام 20 23
التصريح هو لروبرت مارديني مدير اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر الذي حذر من ان
المنظمه لن تستطيع الوصول الى سكان
المناطق التي يصعب الوصول اليها حيث تشتد
الحاجه للمساعده حمل مارديني على المجتمع
الدولي الذي لم يرتقي الى مستوى التحديات
وحكم على مجتمعات تعاني بالنسيان
اما فيديو اليوم فهو من التشيك ينهمك
هؤلاء العمال في الحياكه لان الطلب زاد
بشكل مذهل على بضاعتهم لكنها ليست ملابس
او حتى خياما كبيره وانما هي اسلحه مزيفه
وبالحجم الطبيعي تقريبا دبابات وعربات
مدرعه مصنوعه من الحرير والقماش وهي قابله
للنفخ اما المفارقه انها تستنزف قدرات
الخصوم فهذه التي يبلغ سعرها عده الاف قد
تستهدف بقذيفه يبلغ سعرها 10 او 20 ضعفا
اما سوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من بلجيكا
ليس احتفالا بالالعاب الناريه ولا مهرجان
للالوان وانما هو احتجاج لرجال الاطفال
الاطفاء والغريب انهم خلال احتجاجهم فعلوا
اكثر ما يكرهونه اشعل النيران
الى هنا تنتهي العربيه 360 ولكن الملفات
والاخبار تستمر مع اخبار الساعه والزميل
صهيب اليك صهيب ماذا لديك الليله مساء
الخير ميسون المزيد عن معركه بخموت التي
تبقى مشتعله كذلك تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
السعودي حول ايران
سنتابعك
[موسيقى]